here with an early winner of this round
ali reza tell us a little bit about this
game it seemed like a roller coaster to
take us from the opening over here yeah
i think um i messed up the move order
this line i should not go knight c2
definitely you mean in this position
after queen takes d5 yeah yeah because
here queen h5 but it's still okay of
course it's equal
and yeah i played
normal but
yeah here it's very complicated i mean
it's not clear how black has to develop
also
i think it's easier for me to play a bit
but he played very well actually
a5 b5 bishop d4
yeah here i'm better for sure yes
but i should have played like short
castle or something
now tell us a little bit about this
decision you put the rook on d1 right
and then you decided nah let's put the
work on b1 yeah because here it's
different right i mean here my pawn is
on b5 already so um yeah here is a rugby
one just to have some tricks at some
point also whereas with knight c5 knight
takes e4 works
oh it's just charizard real quick 95
here and i take z4
yeah yeah yeah it works right bishop
yeah and this is why we need the rook on
b1 yeah yes bishop takes b2 he takes c5
yes knight 65 yeah it does work okay
yeah i wanted some tricks like this but
he played c5 he kept his bishop on d4
and here i completely blundered the idea
of bishop still here i spent a lot of
time
um thinking better to include h4 or not
but it's okay and like yeah it's a
blunder i think but but maybe i missed
okay right so
um
the computers weren't so happy about
your position let's put it that way they
were not happy right that was a minus
two minus two yeah queen takes d5 what
did you think was going to happen after
rook f1 yeah i think here he has to play
very concretely i mean c4 i couldn't
after c4 make my position work but
see if in this position there's clamping
down on your pockets right
rook f4 let's say f5
whoa whoa
just yeah because now i don't have d3
right right
you definitely don't have v3
and uh
what what was the line i was thinking
not instead of rook f4
maybe
after c4
uh sephora yeah rook c1 maybe just
attacking the spawn right because he
cannot uh now knight e5 is very
important 95 and if i take on e4 yeah
bishop before queen b5 queen b5 because
knight d3 i take this queen yes let me
show that real quick
knight d3 queen d3 right i know it works
yes this works okay queen distribution
of this race it's an equal but okay it's
fine right now i think what the engines
were saying was actually the move b6
just keeping on to the position
when you when did you play the move
knight f8
what did you analyze
yeah i immediately thought that if queen
c3 did you expect this book no it is
i immediately thought if i quin c3 f6 i
have rook f6 and i'm better because
uh because he has he's not developed and
the pawn on e4 is very weak so
it was very weird move by him right and
queen c3 and he it collapsed suddenly
look at four and here he has to of
course go for some end game i think
some like queen d4
and uh
and here we have some options queen
queen takes on d4
it takes yeah i hear as i said at
minimum i could take and go rookie four
and i'm better it takes takes and rookie
four yes it does look a little more
pleasant for a white test pawn and d4
and strong bishops okay maybe bishop
with five but i could get get a good
position anyway i think right and after
f5 were you surprised by this move as
well yeah i think
he already had to bail out but he was in
shock that he is not winning already
so he was he wanted to still play for
win and
but yeah it didn't turn
after d3 and
still he has to go queen d4 or queen
takes a2 i thought also maybe okay one
coin d5 and immediately go queen d4 like
on the next right
uh what what do you think went through
his mind when he played the move knight
d4 i think uh he blundered the
e3 probably right i mean he thought that
e3 can never be played somehow mr rupp
only 8
but yeah no he after bishop takes f2
he he saw that my position is still
playable he was a bit maybe annoyed i
think that he didn't win immediately
right i think so yeah well you still
gotta win one games and in this one you
came back how do you feel of today's
game satisfied or do you feel that you
shouldn't have blundered yeah i think it
was a very shaky game
obviously i had two rest days so i when
you have tourists you're out of the
competition kind of so
and i'm happy at least i'm back getting
back to the game so um
it's a decent game but okay without this
this plunder i cannot be too happy so
um yeah i take it anyway
of course we take those all right so
what'd you do in the rest days yeah we
we went with eric rosen to tennis and
um yeah and i watched the game yesterday
in also tennis at midnight it was very
interesting so did you say until the end
yeah i stayed over the end it was in i
couldn't sleep because i had to watch it
i might explain bishop to except
yeah that's great well alright so thanks
for joining us here and good luck thank
you
thank you uh alireza congratulations on
your victory today let's